bottles and glasses untouched TVs still
switched on the lighthouse Inn is now a
crime scene of a brutal murder
like normal on Christmas Eve this Pub on
the Wirral was incredibly busy but the
party atmosphere was last night
punctuated by gunfire
is that gone the sound of at least eight
shots was picked up by this woman sat in
a car on the road outside the pub she'd
been inside only moments ago
but it was a 26 year old woman
innocently celebrating with her sister
and friends who were shot in the head in
what police have described as a callous
and cold-blooded murder the fact that
this has happened on Christmas Eve makes
the tragedy even more impalatable and
shows those responsible have no regard
for members of the public who just want
to be able to live their lives without
fear
at the time the offender fired the gun
there were a large number of people
enjoying a night out at the Lighthouse
Inn
and the actions of the gunman were
totally and utterly Reckless
the gunshots injured four others a 28
year old man is tonight in a critical
condition
it's very early stages of the
investigation but we do not believe that
the victim in this case has been
targeted as people were celebrating and
enjoying themselves police believe the
gunman fired several shots towards the
entrance of the pub minutes later a
dark-colored Mercedes was seen leaving
the car park they now want to speak to
that male and vowed they won't rest
until they find who's responsible
the Pub's owners said this is a tragedy
beyond words it left many living nearby
in shock and terrified on what was meant
to be a day of Celebration
what sounded like gunshots and it was
rapid fire probably one after the other
maybe six or seven shots and then
eventually we heard sirens and we knew
that and something bad had happened it's
just your heart sinks doesn't it I mean
a young person just losing their life
like that and others injured you know
it's it's it's hard to describe really
because because it's on your doorstep
it's it's closer to you almost you know
and I think that's the thing you know
we've got family coming for Christmas
day today and this is really black in
the day
as a Manhunt was launched forensic teams
spent hours collecting evidence to
establish what exactly happened here the
police presence across wallacy remains
significant and it's unlikely to lessen
until they catch the person responsible
in saman Rashid Sky News the Wirral